we here at the khan academy are working
on some type of a software project and
we need to think about what's the
optimal number of programmers we should
hire at least think about how much how
much productivity we're getting per
programmer when we are working on this
software project and so what i've done
over here this is a spreadsheet so i'm
not going to be able to write i'll only
be able to type this is microsoft excel
right over here in this column i have
the different numbers of programmers and
then let's say based on other studies or
industry studies or past experience this
tells us how many lines of programming
code we can get per month and obviously
lines of code isn't maybe
the best way to measure things because
someone can write good lines or bad
lines of code but let's just say this is
one way of measuring productivity for
software engineers so the first thing
i'm going to think about is what are my
what are my fixed costs so what am i
going to spend no matter how many
software engineers i hire for this
project and for the sake of this video
my fixed costs will be
the office space and the electricity and
let's assume i just have a
an office that can accommodate any
number of these programmers so that's a
fixed cost that's not going to change
depending on the number of programmers
that i have and then the other fixed
cost let's say i have a product manager
for this project and i'm going to pay
her salary to essentially help spec out
what this pro what this what this
software should should actually do so
her salary is let's say ten thousand
dollars a month and then another five
thousand dollars a month in office space
for everybody so it's going to come out
to 15 000
a month and that's not going to change
regardless of however many programmers i
have so i'm going to go into excel and
go to this little bottom right right
over here and i'm going to drag that
down
and so it's going to be fifteen thousand
dollars in fixed costs no matter how
many programmers i end up hiring
now the variable costs let's assume that
the the full you know sometimes people
well let's just say that the full
compensation for a programmer is ten
thousand dollars a month so if you
include
if you include the cost of their salary
if you include the cost of their health
insurance you include uh you know the
the extra goodies that they will eat
from the company kitchen whatever it
might be so it's going to be ten
thousand dollars a month so my variable
my total variable costs are going to be
ten thousand dollars times the number of
programmers so here i'm going to write
equals
equals and i'm going to write it's going
to be ten thousand dollars per
programmer
times that little snowflake i pressed
shift 8 to get that snowflake times and
i could say times whatever is in that
cell so you see it's
cell d7 and actually let me scroll this
over so you can see
so you can actually see the cells so
that is cell d7 and let me
press enter so that's cell so it's ten
thousand dollars times d7 which is this
one right over here and i just selected
that and i can press enter and right now
that's nothing let me scroll over so we
can see everything a little bit a little
bit better let me scroll over a little
bit to the
there you go i'm having trouble okay
there you go now what are going to be my
total cost my total costs are my fixed
cost plus my variable costs so that's
going to be equal to
and i'm just using my i'm just using my
arrow keys right now it's going to be
equal to f7 right that's cell
f7
plus
this one plus my variable cost my total
costs are my fixed cost plus my variable
costs and so it's fifteen thousand
dollars and actually i can make this
true for every row over here and this is
one of the really useful things about a
spreadsheet is i defined this i define
this cell as being ten thousand dollars
times whatever this cell or times
whatever this cell is right over here
and so what i can just do is i can just
scroll take that drag that all the way
down and for every one of these it's
going to take ten thousand dollars times
the cell that's essentially three to its
left so now it's going to be ten
thousand times d8 this will be ten
thousand times d9 or and let's look at
that so that's we can see right there 10
000 times d9 and you could
if you click on there you can actually
see what the formula is 10 000 times d9
so by dragging that i was able to get
the right formula all the way down now
the total cost for every row here is
going to be 2 to the left plus 1 to the
left and so if i drag that down it will
do that for every row over here
so now this is 25 is the 15 plus the 10.
105 is 15 plus 90 000 our total cost our
fixed cost plus variable costs now let's
think about the average fixed cost and
the average fixed cost we're going to
think about it in fixed costs per line
of code produced and over here line of
code produced is zero so we're going to
get we're going to divide by zero which
is undefined so we could leave that
blank but we could fill this one in so
our total fixed cost this is going to be
our total fixed costs which is cell f8 i
just use the arrow keys to select f8
divided by
divided by our total lines of code per
month
so divided by our total lines of code
per month
and so
that gets me 3.75 fixed costs per line
of code and then i can scroll i can do
the same thing that i've been doing
before i can drag this down and then we
see what the fixed cost is so at any
given point if i take the fixed cost 15
divided by the lines of code i get 1.38
and this actually makes sense because
the more the more programmers i add on
to this project the more lines of code i
get i'm using the same fixed costs i'm
using the same project manager i'm using
the same office space so the cost of
that project manager that office space
gets spread out amongst or along more
and more code so the cost the fixed cost
per line of code goes down as we add
more and more programmers now what is
the what is the average variable cost so
once again the variable cost is going to
be whatever the variable cost is per
lines of code per month so
when we're talking about average we're
talking about average cost per line of
code and maybe i should so this is per
line of code per let me write it over
here
per
line of code
and i can say per month
per line of code per month actually i
wanted that to spread out more but the
way i've set it up so let me scroll down
whoops
let me i'm having issues here all right
well these are all per lined average
average lines of code per month and so
let's think about what happens with our
variable costs so i'm also going to
start here because i don't want to
divide by zero so in this month our
total variable costs were ten thousand
dollars and our total lines of code are
going to be four thousand dollars g8
divided by e8 and so
average variable cost per line of code
is 2.50
and then what happens so let's do that
for every row over here
so when we do it for every row something
interesting happens our average fixed
cost went down because we're taking the
same cost and we're spreading it out
amongst more code but our average
variable costs went up as we added more
programmers per line of code it actually
cost us a little bit more on average per
line of code and that's actually if you
look here as we add the incremental
lines of code we get per programmer is
actually going down that first
programmer by themselves she can write 4
000 lines of code but then that second
programmer is only you're not getting to
8 000 you're getting the 3 000 and
probably because they have to coordinate
with each other they have to plan a
little bit more it's not all in one
person's head
and then when you're at the third one
you're not even adding 3000 lines of
code you're only adding 2 000 lines of
code and this is actually a real
phenomenon that actually happens in
companies the more people you add on to
a product a project obviously they can
maybe do more work but there's also more
coordination there's going to be more
meetings there's going to be more
interruptions and so each person's
individual productivity is going to go
down and this isn't to say that this
third coder is somehow worse than the
first coder all of their on average all
of them are now only going to produce 3
000 code 3 000 lines of code a month
when maybe individually they could have
each produced 4 000 lines of code but
they have to spend some of their
energies now coordinating it and so
that's why our average variable cost per
line of code is going up as we add more
and more people it's getting us
incrementally it's getting it's becoming
more and more expensive on average to
write that line of code and if we look
at average total cost that's going to be
and this is once again this is per line
of code is going to be our total costs
h8
h8 divided by the total lines of code
per month
so
on
if we just hire one engineer we're going
to have 6.25
spent per line of code and that's
because a lot is spent on and these are
this is actually just the sum of these
two right over here and then let me get
let me make that true
set that formula for every row and so we
see something interesting when we start
to hire a few engineers we're able to
spread out our fixed costs even though
our our average variable cost per line
of code are going up our fixed costs are
going down so we're it's actually we're
getting a little bit of a benefit
because we're spreading our fixed costs
per line of code but then it starts to
get expensive again because as we said
the more people you have working on the
project they're going to have to spend
more time coordinating with each other
and and maybe even undoing each other's
work or redoing each other's work as
opposed to just writing the actual
software and now let's think about the
marginal cost the marginal cost the best
way to think about is what is the
incremental cost of that next set of
line of code so one way to think about
it so this is going to be how much more
you're spending divided by how much more
code you're getting so how much more so
for example how much more
and this is going to be once again per
line of code so once again so we're
getting we're spending when we go from
zero programmers to one programmer we're
going from fifteen thousand dollars of
total cost to twenty five thousand
dollars of total cost so we're going
from we do in parentheses 25 if we're
going from 15 to 20 to 25 that means
we're increasing our expenditure by 25
minus 15 and so that's why i'm doing h8
minus h7 so that's how much more we're
spending in expenditures and then how
much more code are we getting well we're
getting we're getting 4 000
minus 0 lines of code and the reason why
i'm doing the formula this way is so
that when we drag it down on all the
rows the formula will be right because
it's relatively taking the right cells
into account
and the reason why i'm saying it's
average is because this is saying what's
the incremental cost per line of code
for this first four thousand lines of
code and then we can go from there
and we can drag it down and now this
tells us the incremental cost per code
for the next three thousand lines of
code and once again it got a little bit
more expensive because we're getting a
little bit less efficient as we add more
and more people
and there's something very interesting
that happens here and you might have
even noticed it in these numbers over
here we actually get a negative marginal
cost and this isn't meaning that when we
add more lines of code somehow we're
getting money it's actually saying that
as we spend more money we're actually
we're actually killing lines of code
because at some point if you have too
many people on this one project team
they actually start killing each other's
productivity and you can even see it
right here in the numbers when we had
seven people we were able to write 11
400 lines of code but then the eighth
person because of coordination it's not
that this eighth person is incompetent
it just when you have eight people in a
team everyone's productivity goes down
so that you're only able to produce 11
200 lines of code and that's why you had
this negative marginal cost now when you
get to eight people all of a sudden by
ad spending more dollars you're actually
destroying some of what you are actually
trying to produce so what i wanted to do
here is just to really get you behind
the numbers and really maybe give you a
little sense of how you can actually do
this with a spreadsheet and get you
thinking a little bit about how a firm's
cost structure might actually work